House of the Dragon starts filming in a few
days and airs next year. This Game of Thrones
prequel show will tell the story of the Dance
of the Dragons, a Targaryen civil war that
took place over 100 years before Game of Thrones.
In January, HBO announced they are developing
a show based on George R.R. Martin’s Tales
of Dunk and Egg series, which follows the
legendary knight Ser Dunk the Tall and his
squire, the Targaryen prince, Egg. This series
is set 90 years before Game of Thrones.
Raised as Dunk in Flea Bottom, Duncan became
a squire of the hedge knight Arlan of Pennytree.
Duncan then traveled the Seven Kingdoms as
a hedge knight himself, with the young Prince
Aegon Targaryen, called "Egg", as his squire.
The early exploits of "Dunk and Egg" are chronicled
in A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms, which collects
The Hedge Knight, The Sworn Sword, and The
Mystery Knight.
Ser Duncan the Tall was a great knight in
the history of Westeros that served loyaly
to House Targaryen. He was a famous warrior
and a great friend and champion to King Aegon
V Targaryen. He's immortalized in many songs
and stories. The pair of "Dunk and Egg" had
many famous adventures. This included a visit
to Dorne, where they were nearly killed by
the apparently insane Lady of Vaith, as well
as resolving a decades-long dispute between
the houses Osgrey and Webber in the Reach.
They also helped foil the Second Blackfyre
Rebellion before undertaking a lengthy journey
north to visit Winterfell. Many years later
Egg ascended the Iron Throne as King Aegon
V Targaryen. Ser Duncan the Tall became a
member of the Kingsguard, and later its Lord
Commander. Duncan was one of the heroes of
the Fourth Blackfyre Rebellion. Egg and Dunk
faced their last adventure together at Summerhall,
on the night of the great fire which killed
them, the same night Rhaegar Targaryen was
born there. HBO is also working on a show
about Robert’s Rebellion which ended a 300
years old Targaryen dynasty in Westeors, and
almost ended Targaryens themselves. To everyone
who watched Game of Thrones, Robert’s Rebellion
is quite known. Robert, Ned Stark and Jon
Arryn rebelled against the Mad King and overthrew
Targaryens. It lasted "close to a year" and
resulted in the end of the Targaryen dynasty
in the Seven Kingdoms and the beginning of
Robert Baratheon's reign. It had 10 major
battles and ultimately resulted with the victory
for the rebels, the end of the Targaryen dynasty,
and the start of the Baratheon dynasty. This
show will bring many characters we know and
love back on the screens. Ned Stark, Robert
Baratheon, Tywin Lannister, Rhaegar Targaryen
and Lyanna Stark, the Mad King etc. And if
you thought this was good enough news, well
there’s more. As many as 3 more new Game
of Thrones prequels have been announced to
be in work, or rather in a developing stage
in HBO. First of the 3 new prequels is called:
10,000 ships. 10,000 Ships is a reference
to the journey made by warrior queen Princess
Nymeria and the surviving members of the Rhoynars,
who travelled from Essos to Dorne following
their defeat by the Valyrian Freehold in the
Second Spice War. She lost, but rather to
submit to their rule, she led her people across
the Narrow Sea and settled in Dorne, which
her descendants would rule for generations
to come. She and her people came to this new
land in 10,000 ships, which Nymeria burned,
preventing any of her men from wanting to
go home or somewhere else and giving a clear
sign that this strange Dornish land is their
new home. While legends often claim that Nymeria
commanded a fleet of ten thousand ships, Beldecar,
the inside of A Song of Ice and Fire author
of the History of the Rhoynish Wars whose
copy can be found in the Red Keep's library
argues that the number was inflated, perhaps
by tenfold. While other chroniclers offer
other numbers, in truth no count was ever
made.
Maester Yandel agrees that Nymeria led a great
many ships, mostly river craft, skiffs, poleboats,
trading galleys, fishing boats, rafts, and
pleasure barges, crammed with women, children,
and old men. Beldecar insists only one in
ten was seaworthy`. At the time of Nymeria's
arrival, Dorne was a poor land where a score
of lords and petty kings quarreled over rivers,
wells, and fertile water. Many viewed the
Rhoynar as unwelcome invaders who should be
driven back into the sea. However, Lord Mors
Martell of the Sandship saw an opportunity
in the Rhoynar—and singers claim that Lord
Martell also lost his heart to a beautiful
princess. With many trained in warfare, the
Rhoynar added their strength to Lord Martell's
own, increasing his host by tenfold. Mors
married Nymeria, and hundreds of his knights,
squires, and bannermen wed Rhoynish women,
uniting the two people by blood. The Rhoynar
also brought considerable wealth with them
and their artisans and armorers' skills were
far advanced than those of their Westerosi
counterparts. To celebrate these unions and
to ensure that her people could not retreat
to the sea again, Nymeria burned her fleet,
declaring her wanderings to be at an end,
although some of her people mourned the loss
of their ships. Nymeria named her husband
the Prince of Dorne, declaring his dominion
over all of Dorne. However, such supremacy
was not an easy feat and years of war followed,
called Nymeria's War. The Rhoynar and the
Martells subdued one petty king after another,
and no fewer than six kings were sent to the
Wall to join the Night's Watch by Nymeria
and her husband. Soon, only King Yorick V
Yronwood remained, the greatest of the Dornish
kings. Nymeria and the Martells battled against
Yronwood and his bannermen for nine years.
When her husband fell to Yronwood's sword
in the Third Battle of the Boneway, Nymeria
assumed sole command of the Martell armies.
Two more years of battle followed, but Nymeria
eventually defeated Yorick V and he bent the
knee to her, ensuring Martell supremacy. Thereafter
Nymeria ruled from Sunspear, the new seat
of House Martell built around Sandship. This
migration took place around 1,000 years before
the events depicted in A Song of Ice and Fire
novels. Arya Stark named her direwolf after
Nymeria. The second new prequel is named:
Flea Bottom. Flea Bottom is the poorest slum
district in King’s Landing, a maze-like
warren of narrow streets and dark alleys filled
with tanneries and ale houses. It’s featured
many times in Game of Thrones, including when
Arya Stark takes refuge there after fleeing
the Red Keep. Characters from Flea Bottom
include Ser Davos Seaworth, Gendry and Karl
Tanner, a brother of the Night’s Watch.
The famous hedge knight, Ser Duncan the Tall
is also from Flea Bottom. The third and final
new Game of Thrones prequel is called: 9 Voyages.
9 Voyages refers to the great voyages at sea
made by Corlys Velaryon known as Sea Snake
aboard the Sea Snake ship. By the of age seven-and-thirty,
Corlys was hailed as the greatest seafarer
the Seven Kingdoms had ever known. Corlys
was said to be as brilliant as he was restless,
and as adventurous as he was ambitious. Corlys
Velaryon, known as the Sea Snake, was a fabled
Lord of the Tides, Master of Driftmark, and
head of House Velaryon. He was the husband
of Princess Rhaenys Targaryen. During the
Dance of the Dragons, he became Hand to Queen
Rhaenyra Targaryen. Lord Velaryon journeyed
to places including Pentos, Dragonstone and
around the bottom of Westeros as well as to
Lys, Tyrosh and Myr. He reached the fabled
lands of Yi Ti and Leng, whose wealth doubled
that of the House Velaryon, and him and the
Ice Wolf headed north searching for passage
around the top of Westeros, only to find frozen
seas and icebergs as big as mountains. The
show chronicles Corlys Velayrion’s adventures.
Interestingly, lord Corlys will also play
a big role in House of the Dragon and this
prequel will only get more interest by fans
when House of the Dragon airs and everyone
falls in love with the Sea Snake character.
In conclusion, HBO is working on many Game
of Thrones prequel shows, and beside House
of the Dragons, none of these will air before
2023 at earliest. But this is all good news
and don't worry about the release dates of
these prequels. As confirmed by HBO's president,
House of the Dragon will air in 2022 which
is in just one year.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer. It’s based on George RR Martin’s
book Fire And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s
yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
The key event of the show is also the key
in the history of House Targaryen, the Dance
of the Dragons - the Targaryen civil war,
which divided the entire kingdom and launched
a huge war that was fought from 129 AC to
131 AC. The Dance of the Dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the Seven
Kingdoms. The war of succession between Aegon
II and his half-sister Rhaenyra over their
father Viserys I's throne. Both of them thought
they belonged on the Iron Throne. When people
started declaring for one of them or the other,
their fight divided the kingdoms in two. Targaryens
fought Targaryens, brothers fought brothers,
dragons fought dragons. By the time it was
over, thousands were dead. House of the Dragon
is coming with many Targaryens and their dragons
as well as with other legendary characters
such as Sea Snake, Cregan Stark and his Winter
Wolfs, Red Kraken and many more.Thank you
so much for watching and please let me know
which prequel you're looking forward the most.